number four i wanted to play this for
you not to belabor the point but we were
talking about the media's encouragement
of writing
and i played a few examples for you but
this i just saw before we went on the
air here tom elliott at grabian
media put together i think it's a pretty
powerful
i didn't even show you the half of it
this is a pretty powerful 90-second
compilation that i just want to play for
you just just
just to show you it says the media's
history of supporting antifa it's just
from
most of this is from the last the past
few months
and here's what it sounds like i argue
to you tonight
all punches are not equal
morally in the eyes of the law yes
but in the eyes of good and evil here's
the argument
they are strictly principled
anti-fascists
and what they see in the trump
administration and what they see
happening in this country
they see they see the neo-fascism that
we see
and they've taken a principle stand to
stand against white supremacists and
white nationalists wherever they may
show up
it says it right in the name antifa
anti-fascism which is what they were
there
um fighting listen there's you know no
organization is perfect there's some
violence
i think that a lot of people recognize
that when pushed self-defense is a
legitimate response to white supremacist
and neo-nazi violence
the problem is to equate the violence in
reaction against bigotry
with the bigotry itself is to
misunderstand the fact that when you go
to cancer treatment
the radiation is tough treatment but it
is meant to remove the cancer
there's a group of anti-fascists called
the black bloc which do
tend to get violent their idea is look
non-violence hasn't worked and we
are going to try to stop this but they
wouldn't have been there they wouldn't
have been anywhere near there
had it not been for the fact that white
supremacists neo-nazis were out
scaring the living day loud out of most
of the people
in that town sluggishness is
thuggishness wherever it comes from
politically and we should be the first
to call it out i disagree
i disagree i know we shouldn't cut it we
shouldn't call out all thuggishness
not the kind that i like and that that
really is the difference i mean
if they're being honest uh the media
and they were to respond to the charge
of hypocrisy on this issue
where they were openly supporting
rioting for months and now
pretending to be shocked and appalled by
it
um and and violence and all that and
their honest answer is that it it's okay
when we do it
that's it it's it is it's okay when we
do it
and if if if they're doing it for a
leftist cause
and especially if they're if their
victims are you know
the have the right uh ideology and skin
color then
right in terms of right for for for
being the victim
then it's okay that's their answer
that's really what they believe that's
that's i guess the advantage
of being a moral relativist that you
don't have to hold yourself to any
standard at all
something can be totally wrong
when one person does it and totally okay
when someone else does
because there is no moral there is no
objective moral truth there is no
universal
moral standard that everybody has held
to and that's what we're seeing here
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated